c'est dur c'est dur d'avoir 20 en 2020
c'est dur donc je donnerais jamais de
leçon à nos jeunes parce que ce sont
ceux qui honnêtement vivent un sacrifice
terrible des examens annulé de l'
angoisse pour les formations de l'
angoisse pour trouver le premier job
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on a mis une
telle mobilisation
un jeune une solution je rappelle que
nous avons créé des nouvelles formations
on a justement réouvert des places pour
que des jeunes puissent rester refaire
des formations en faculté comme en cfa
comme dans des écoles post bac on à
développer l'apprentissage massivement
en accompagnant les entreprises pour
qu'elles puissent leur donner des places
en apprentissage et des chiffres se
tiennent à peu près dans cette rentrée
et donc en payant beaucoup plus en
compensant l'employeur pour que les
jeunes puissent trouver leur place donc
on fera tout pour nos jeunes